Hey, what's going on? It's spilled and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast yet.
Ah, just checking. Yeah,
just checking in on you. Um,
I hope this isn't too loud.
On Sunday I'll get a fucking producer.
Um,
it's the last day of
the world as we know it.
It's the last day of the year and uh,
I have a very special guest on
the podcast, also the house guest,
uh, New Jersey Zone, the pride of
Trenton. Please welcome Mr. Paul Versey.
What is up bill?
Nothing.
We've just been enjoying the drama of the
morning waiting for Jason Lyon and fly
of the world as he knows it
and Jay doesn't feel fine.
Do these text messages
he's been sending me.
Jay Lie had got snowed in and Cleveland
and he was freaking out that he was
going to miss the fucking rose bowl.
So you know,
we fucking did a little thing or whatever.
You've got a flight and he's fine.
He has a flight and he just eat the
whole time. He's so fucking dramatic.
All right, man. What did he say? Pray for
me. Pray for me. This is unbelievable.
They can make a movies.
Oh yeah,
do they could make a movie
about me trying to get,
trying to get back to the rose bowl.
It's like, dude, you have a ticket.
The plane's going to leave.
It connects to Dallas.
Where's the conflict in the
movie? There is no like, oh,
here's the doll in his head. Uh,
it's the funniest. We Love Jay,
but he's the best did.
But this guy is constantly falling.
These fucking things. Like some
of the shit he says, he goes,
he could text me this morning. He goes,
looks like I'm going to be all good.
Flight is on time. Audit
Dallas. It's like, yeah,
why wouldn't it be once you
get out of Cleveland airspace,
you headed south? Yeah.
It's like, was he waiting for the
taxi to break down? Like there's no,
I have no idea. So he goes,
he goes, I love it. He goes,
flight is on time out of debt. Looks like
I'm going to be okay. So I write, okay,
great. And then he goes, and then I
go out, you know what's, you know,
I got the regular charcoal in the natural
stuff for the stuff we're going to
smoke. What we did with the whole rose
bowl. Yeah. Tailgate checklist here,
you know, sound good. And he goes, yes,
sounds good. And then he goes, great,
may have jinxed myself.
They just send out that announced that
maintenance is on the plane and they will
update us in 15 minutes was
supposed to board 10 minutes ago.
This is fucking insane. It's
like, hey, it's going to be,
it's the yen Bellville world as he knows
it. And I just wrote back, I the funny,
I wrote back, you'll be fine and
yield then and we got to sig,
you'll be fine. Uh, my God
dude. And then he goes,
a lot of Hawkeye fans on
this flight translation,
a lot of fucking ugly to people
like that. And I said, yeah,
the big ten's a little rough, you
know? And he goes, yeah, we make,
we make Lyman and full backs and then
it goes boarding. Now thank Christ.
I mean, I've never, I've never
seen it in like it. Jay's is like,
if the other shoe could drop, nope.
He's almost willing it to drop.
I swear to God to play crashes.
I'm blaming him. It's not
going to be pilot error.
It's him in the back. Just gone like,
God, God, turbulence. Here we go.
It's the end of the
world. Yeah, I, we got it.
We got to fucking tease amount of it. He's
never going to, that's who he is, dude.
He's got to see this. We all got
our things. That's his. I know.
I get all worked up about fucking
star wars do. We were drinking.
We're drinking cognac last night and I
was flipping out about star wars once
again. Oh Dude. You Changed Moods.
It was, I'd never, you went from,
you would've thought somebody told you,
you know horrible. Oh yeah. You just,
you were like, compared to what I
would try, it drives me fucking nuts.
You just nine is better than any of
those fucking things. No, I know a dude.
But then after that you just looked at
your drink for a second and we're shaking
your head. And I was like, I think
he's, he really mad. I don't know.
I just know exists. This
fucking drives me nuts. Like
just say you enjoy the movie. Don't be
like, oh wait, it's fucking bullshit.
It isn't. It isn't that. I don't know
why it bugs me. It just bothers me. What?
I just have to be like,
what? Jesus Christ.
If you think that's the
greatest movie ever,
what do you do when you see raging bull?
I honestly questioned if you got into it
with somebody in the past about it and
it's still with like in you,
like to,
something happened like the way you got
mad. I was like the business, it's like,
is there something I'm missing?
You know, you know what it was?
Cause I had tequila before the Cognac.
It was just all that hard stuff
was that Tequila was unreal. Yeah.
Oh I thought that was a good
one. Oh, that was unbelievable.
But would be an angel's today cause we've
got two shows tonight at the Orpheum
and your eggs. Oh my God. And your
eggs. Oh yeah. You know what, Paula?
Like medium. Paulie likes the eggs over
medium, numb over medium. That's the,
you have to care. It's an art.
You got it. You got to care.
They make over medium over easy. It just
fucking flippity ago over over hard.
You just burn it up all the medium.
You can't and you gotta pay attention.
You nailed it over medium as you cut the
middle of the yoke and it doesn't even
go all over the place. It just slowly
oozes out. It's still soft. You nailed it.
You know the and, and the waffles. Dude,
I gotta tell you I haven't had
a bad meal out here. Oh yeah.
Been cooking up a storm for first.
He and his lovely wife here every morning
having a great time. Scrambled eggs.
Fucking ah, walk. I'm on the flight and
fluffy with the cheese in there. He can't.
Yeah, no, it's great. As a cook I am Blah.
Hits 10 times better, you know? Yeah.
I'm mad out of the special. It's
probably got a break. I've, I had,
I don't know what's going to happen.
We got to get him on here at
tease him about that. We Love Jay.
We just fucking around. But
until you, these text messages,
I swear to God to pray for me would think
is pray for me is so ridiculously over
the top. I looked the guy in the movie,
the sniper didn't have dialogue like this.
He's just trying to make a
connecting flight and you know what?
I want to look up Dallas right now and
I'm going to see what the fucking way,
if had to guess, what is the weather
judging by those texts, you know,
they had to have been like
a tornado warning, right?
I bet you the weather there is
like 48 degrees of 55 degrees.
Okay. Clear skies. I mean, I don't
know if I'll ever take off. You know,
it's 51 degrees. I almost
nailed it. Precipitation,
0% humidity. Humidity's 0%
winds, 10 miles an hour. Nothing.
Dude, you could barely fly a kite
and I'll get a weather drone.
Wouldn't have turbulent Jesus Christ.
Check.
Uh, uh, sorry if I got a little
heated last night. I don't
know. When I, when I get,
when I drink the fucking hard
stuff sometimes it brings out,
it brings out the uglier side of me.
It was so funny man.
Like Stacy and I were just like,
I did he get like,
it was really funny cause you got, you
went from like, we've just, by the way,
that Cognac, Oh yeah, Paul, Yours
also got, and I'm a lunatic. You know,
you realize I'm a lunatic.
Yeah, but no, but no, but I
don't think you're a lunatic.
I just know I am. Look at Jay
flips out over fucking nothing.
I flip out over like Jay slips out.
I basically,
but everything I've slipped
out over like dumb shit dude.
You Act like your high
school rival loves star Wars.
No, I lost it. My high school,
I had this thing and he was a star
wars guy and you weren't dude.
That's how I just want someone
to agree with me. It's like,
what am I not seeing that reminded
me, you Chappelle, please believe me.
Nobody just be like, this is the
greatest thing ever. And like, like,
Oh, some Rockwell and moon was
fucking up like that blue, that move.
We blew my fucking mind. You
know, I didn't see that. Ah, yeah,
I didn't want you to do that.
And they go watch one scene with he walks
and I want you to justify that fucking
50 mile lied. I though I understand
is for kids. I get that. If you're,
whatever I do,
I can I let you go.
I lost my mind is the adults
that are still getting like,
I mean this movies that I loved when I
was a kid and I watched them now and I'm
just like, oh Jesus. You know, dude,
I actually see what you're saying.
I like star wars because I was a kid
and I saw, I see. It's ridiculous.
The big monkey to Chewbacca Tourette's,
just funding,
you know, but, but,
but then there's a cool side to it too,
like evil and good and the same.
I like the light saber fights, dude.
I just, you know, but as a kid,
I was extensive thing. I was a kid.
Okay, you like light saber fight.
Once you watch enter the
dragon with Bruce Lee,
I mean you want to see some good fighting.
Even remember talking to people with a
flashlight and I'll remember talking to
yesterday and they're like,
all go into the hall
while, wow, that's a
fucking no, remember we were
on the charity must sit.
Yeah,
I tell me the fucking same voiceover guy
or did Jabba the hut in fucking Yoda is
not the same guy.
The guy with the hands and say,
I did the cookie monster
job, or no bother. I think
it's the guy from Amistad.
It's all the same thing.
But here's the thing, dude.
You know when you go into a sneaker
store and you're like, oh my God,
those Jordans bring me back. It's the same
thing. And you're like, oh, Jj Abrams.
Well, yeah, he's a good director.
Let's see what he does with it.
You got to check it out, dude.
It's two hours of your life.
That's how I look at it. It's two
hours of your life. Now, to your point,
being dressed online as
Chewbacca, that's crazy. You know,
be having gowns and like,
you know,
women dressed in the princess lay of
bikini with the hair done. That's, so,
that's a little much, I would
never do that. I just say a man,
like give it a chance as it was. He did
a really good job. That's all. I'm not,
I'm not saying it's not a good movie,
but I'm just saying,
it just blows my mind that this is not,
you can have a two mile long line
for that fucking movie. Well,
how many long a mile should it
be? Full, full moon district nine.
It wasn't taught Moonraker or just
actually good of science fiction.
Yeah. I just think I love
that too. I don't mind.
I come to the future when,
you know,
there's no water and all that type of
shit and we fucking destroyed ourselves.
And you know, I'm not in design B's. I
don't like that to meet. This was good.
Brings was, that was the shit for me.
If this was good, that was the shit.
I love that movie. I liked that movie.
Uh, uh, I'm gonna said Riddick Bowe thing.
Rhames ving Rhames did, uh, you know,
the one with the monster couldn't see me.
He had to move the same way he did. Do
you remember that? No. Fucking rent those.
He had the diesel vin diesel.
Sorry,
I didn't see [inaudible].
That's why I thought the guy
they act of thing was rig bull.
Redick Redick and then I went to Bang
Bang. Yes. See how my brain works?
Riddick boats. But your name's in the
words while Paul do what you gotta do.
Jewish sourced up Annapolis to do,
I looked at with chef Gordon was
going number 24, number 24, the light.
No, we were all, we were all over each
other also to heavy heavy vodkas in,
you know, we were hammered in the
first period. Am I don't know,
it's kind of a reoccurring,
a story of a,
speaking of which Paul you're saying
in the, uh, the beginning of 2016.
Yeah. Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
You're going to put it over. Yeah.
And my wife and I talked
about it. I called you up. I
said it. I'm doing it 100%.
Starting after this trip.
This is my last hurrah.
I got three days people and then I'm
going to go, I want to go six months,
but I'm definitely going 90
days clean, dry, no booze.
I'm cutting out the carbs,
going,
going to the track and a run and
I'm going to drop. Uh, you know,
the funny thing about me is my
doctor always said, he goes, dude,
you're the same way. It always, he goes,
you just got to lose a little bit of his
stomach. And he goes, I do do exercise.
I'm like,
I've been 15 pounds overweight for fucking
10 years and I'm getting a 15 pounds
done. Done. What about sticks? So Gosh,
it's going to be a, it's
going to have to be, uh,
it's going to have to be a serious
occasion is going to have to be a serious
occasion. Okay. It's going to have
to be a holiday. I'm dropping back.
I mean, maybe one a month.
That's what I'm going to do.
It's going to be a special occasion.
Well, actually, when they say when you,
you want to really make a change, you
should just try to do one thing at a time.
So I think just not boozing alone,
you'll probably take off half the fucking
weight. Right. Not boozing alone and,
and just not smoking a
stick. You, Joe Zimmerman,
you don't always a funny comic dude.
Funny comment from I think that DC
area is that they're really funny.
And we were doing the road together and
they'd go, hey Joe, did you smoke cigars?
And he just looked at me and he just goes,
only when I celebrate and the way he
said it though, do it. It was just like,
it made me realize, what am I doing?
Oh No, it's stupid. It's, yeah,
it's ridiculous to knock it off. You
know, way better than me though. Yeah.
I'm kind of overwhelmed to be
honest with you. It's like I can't,
I just can't do it anymore.
I just can't,
like I can't fucking just wake up
with that taste in my mouth again.
I can't do like,
I got rid of my human doors and all that.
I don't even have cigars in the
house anymore. And it's just like,
if somebody calls me up, I got
a buddy of mine that, you know,
like once every six weeks, like, you
know, hey man, yeah, you want to go ahead?
And I said, all right, I'll go, I'll
go do that. But like, uh, you know,
I know you dropped off with them when
you used to call me and we'd talk about
certain brands and sticks and you stopped.
Like you used to be like, oh dude,
I went to the thing, I
got this, you know, I'll,
I'll send you a picture of the
label and you stopped that.
I noticed that you stopped. I had to knock
it off, but like I still, I still like,
I like the cigar, but, um, I don't, um,
yeah, it just, it just kind of Chi
just, I had too many and I just,
somewhere on that last bus trip we
did right before the New York shows,
um, I just had it, I think when we
were in that great one in Milwaukee,
but we were just like,
just the doors were all closed.
There was 20 people smoke now
that that was brutal. Yeah.
The next day I was just
like, oh my God dude. Like I,
I feel like that when like
that smoke one of them,
the marrow in my bones here that I,
and I could tell when Steven
[inaudible] was with us,
he wanted to be with us and hang out,
but he couldn't,
he when he was sitting there,
I knew he was just like,
it was way too much people in there
smoking. Oh yeah. And it made it brutal.
There was like 10 guys and then like for
women showed up and they were smoking.
It was smoking. We were one
little room. It was awesome.
But I would say it was too, it
was too much. Yeah. Yeah, I do.
But I gotta tell you to do California
will be a problem for me cause you could
just go out here and just in the sunshine
and just smoke a stick and ball every
day. Yesterday I go, I'm gonna
smoke half of this with a coffee.
I don't need a clip at the end of it. Once
I start going but not do it, I'm, yeah,
I'm going, I'm going clean.
I said to my wife too, I go,
you don't think you're going
to do it? And she goes, no,
I actually know you're going to this time.
I'm definitely doing it.
I'm definitely doing it too.
I don't think you're gonna make it.
I of course you don't know. I'm just using
reverse psychology. I'm going to make,
I'm going to do, I feel one of those
guys, you know one of those guys.
You need to be like, dude. People
said people said I couldn't do it.
Yeah. Wait, you don't understand. When
I put my mind, just stuff that we do,
the funniest shit talker ever. I'm a
time when we were on the fucking road,
you know [inaudible] he's
on the fucking elliptical.
Does like 40 minutes now and I did over
an hour and I crushed it. That one.
I don't want your to do over an hour
bill. I did an hour. I had a time,
then I did an hour. Now the next time
I ask you why I did it, 15 minutes.
That was what it was
on, whatever, whatever.
I did an hour because I made sure
I did six. What Paul goes, he goes,
looks at me and he goes,
no one goes harder than me at the gym
and I'm dying laughing like you didn't
lift one. Wait, you
didn't. When he pulled up,
he got on that like some chick who just
had a baby and you try to lose your baby
bump that you are on a fucking
elliptical for an hour.
I was on the elliptical for an
hour. I went hard for now, but yeah,
I did nothing else. Like no
pull ups. No, no. Yeah, no.
Doing the butterfly through the fucking
pool, like some of these maniacs to duty.
The thing is you see who the fuck are you?
So people who go hard at the gym,
you'll look at it and they look
like statues. They go hard. Yeah.
We just show up and try to,
we try to maintain, yeah,
would. I've been going to my gym recently
to do an hour done. It's hilarious.
Getting back to uh, you know, going
to the gym and stuff like this month,
I want to make sure I went on a lot just
cause I knew it was going to eat like a
fucking animal. And uh, there was like,
you know the, you know the workout couple,
you know? Oh yeah. So like the fucking
dude is just jacked and she is fucking,
she's like,
like she's probably lifting 60% of what
the fuck he's lifting and that she had
these giant fake tits and she
had this look on her face.
Like she didn't want to be there.
She was one of the scariest people
have ever seen in my life. Shit. Hair.
I'll pull back Chin like
this scowl on her face.
And she had like these fucking
world war two like pinup girl,
like the member was bullet tits.
They used to have back then because of
the way they used to shape the bras.
She's walking around in this sports bra.
Like I swear to God,
if this woman wanted to, uh, just
pick me up and body slammed me,
she could dress in Latino. And they also
do that. They like that couple that like,
you know, uh, and she probably had an ass
like me. They got their notice noticing.
No, but they were like, they were all that
workout, do that workout shit. I don't,
I don't get it like these
fucking, these fucking uh, uh,
Mr Mom sweatpants that I have,
which are fucking,
I can't throw them off because
they just won't wear out.
I have had these things for like 12 years.
I don't get these people just
constantly buying the latest like yeah,
they'll buy the latest
Jim Shit. Jim Shit. Yeah.
So like the latest Cim shit now as you
have the socks that looked like they have
the bones going up the Achilles
and then they got oh yeah, again,
like to like the vertebrae,
whatever.
And then they got the things like goes
up on a status that's a Jim status thing.
That's like, listen, I'm a regular and
you just show up. Like this is my home.
You fucking dope.
I never understood how that Nice Jim Shit.
It's like you're going to go there and
sweat your balls off. Like I go in,
I trust like a bomb day. Live forward,
dude, I've talked to those guys.
They're like, Jim is part of the gym
and they go their dress nice. Yeah,
it was a part of, it's just, you know,
it's like the same way I show
up on the golf course, right.
It's come walking out there wearing
either sneakers at Timberlands,
whatever I have on you. Actually
Dude, I remember. Do you actually,
if you don't give a fuck and you
never will, I could tell, but duty,
I will use a putter and a Sandra,
you were hitting some good gifts.
Guy gave a fuck. Yeah, you don't
care. I the dumbest thing and I,
and I just don't like dude fucking having
to sit there and watch somebody line
it up for fucking what seems like
20 minutes. It's just like, dude,
you know you're going to slice
it and then they'd stand out.
That I wanted to do a bit about that.
Just imitating somebody fucking standing
over the ball when he went all of that
shit and doing the thing with the head
and fucking relax. Now who does it?
Why does a thing with his
head, my brother's got this
other thing that he does.
I was going to combine everybody's
little tick and then they lend,
they fucking hit it and it goes into
the woods and then they had the nerve to
stand there. Like they don't understand
what just happened. It's like, dude,
did you forget the last 12 holes?
She been doing it the whole fucking day.
You don't have any money on it. Well,
you just go up and hit the fucking thing.
This pizza behind. That's another
thing. Can't stand about God.
Fucking stress of the people behind me.
I'm just like,
I'm ruining these people's
Day, dude. The lion,
the lion head nod thing, he does
it. He's almost eight golf for the,
you know, he's a very good guy. He's a
good golfer. A Golfer too, but like, uh,
he's bit, Jane's changed
about seven, eight trucks.
Better Golfer than I am because
he's out here. I can't mean he's,
he plays a lot more than I do. I mean, I
don't know if I'll ever play again. I bet
you loved,
you loved how I didn't like when he was
doing the gimmes all when we do a bit.
Yeah,
cause I was like,
well that's another thing too is the
amount of cheating that goes on where
people hit the ball.
I'm going to hit another one.
I mean you're going to count that
one. Not the worse. It's a gimme dude.
I count every fortnight. What did I,
what I shoot on knife like 120 no,
no, no, no. You, you were,
you and Barnick or in like you shot 70
salary shall I guess 58 or 60 [inaudible]
and Barnet shy like high fifties and
you shout like low sixties or whatever.
I counted every of every single
stroke and I didn't take one.
Gimme that's such a
pussy fucking yeah it is.
[inaudible] was little. I had to
yell. He was so far away from the cup.
Yeah. And bought, you're
going to take out a five iron.
That's part of me wanted to like
hurry up. So he was like, no,
just pick it up and you know me
did. I was like, Nah, you can't. Oh,
that was my favorite game within the game.
Watching the two of you guys competing.
Yeah.
Cause you guys are both good golf Stewart.
And then what's his face? Dot. John?
The bus driver was 36.
Yeah, he had a 30, 36 to
36 do that. Oh my God, that is on pace
to do 70 was he was, he was, yeah. He's,
he was a good golfer. John. See
what? This is a man. That's funny.
All right. I'm just making sure there's
isn't something from the venue. So Paula,
what are you busting out tonight for new
year's w Alpha wise. Oh, you know me.
You on fresh classic kicks.
I'm not doing the Jordan zone.
Doing the Rod Lavers I took,
I took [inaudible] to a
friend of ours recommended.
I said, all right, I got a big time
east coast sneakerhead coming out here.
Where should I take him? And boy,
did he nail it? Uh, he said he,
the one was that fight club dude.
It was a motherload.
Like it was like a system overload
my head. Like what you were,
you were with the dog next door. And
I walked in and I saw Jordan, threes,
Jordan, fours, fives. The Senate threes
is what you want. And I couldn't,
I couldn't tell. How about my wife? How
about my wife? Dude, this is my wife.
Stacy's out here with me and she's
having an absolute great too.
The funny thing about her
is she never turns it off.
So we're walking on Melrose in the
sunshine, getting ready to eat lunch,
going into stores, everything she
loves and her brain couldn't handle it.
She's like, I don't have anything to do.
What the fuck she has kids and Becky's.
Yeah, yeah. You know, she's got that like
you ain't shit. You know, she can't relax.
I can relax, Bill. You know that
I can relax. You know what I mean?
I could put my feet up. She can't
said when we were walking around,
she was just like, this is an angle you
haven't fun. And she's like, I might,
I don't know if you know what to do, how
Larry, you know what to do, so you're,
you're inside. And she just goes,
look, they got the Jordan threes, Paul.
They got them.
She goes,
I've been looking for him and I look
underneath and it says 800 bucks.
And she goes,
let me just let me just get them for you.
Let's just get them and I can't
get, first of all, I was like,
it's marked up insanely. What are they
huge? This still usually get five or six,
you know, but I'll bear a
sneaker. I was like, I can't go.
I guess like I like them but I don't like
them to pay to 50 extra on top of the
girls present already is. So she's a
close, just do it. And I was like, no.
But then I saw the fourth,
the fours and the fives do it.
I would before you walked in
there, my eyes, if you just saw my,
I can't believe you know
all of Stacy just send,
my jaw dropped and I was just like looking
at all of these things the same way.
I can list all like the
super bowl champions,
the way that you know all
the Jordan's sneakers.
Like I Yab I'm not as good as
certain people, but I'm, I'm getting,
do you know what's weird is I'm turning
into a sneaker head more and more cause
you got to wear it. Listen, when you
get older, I told you got to be a man.
Needs to things. I was always
taught this. You know what they are?
A man needs a nice watch on his
wrist and an alibi and a nice
and a nice pair of shoes. Whether
it's kicks or shoes, they got up.
I don't know about the kicks things.
I don't remember the kicks.
If I'm just saying the foot game
needs to be on par, you know.
That's what I'm saying. Whatever you
look when somebody looks at your feet,
it's like, oh my God, those are
crazy. You. Whatever sneakers you get.
I either love him or I just,
you either go,
those are classics and I love them
while you're like, I hate them. Yeah.
Because there's a generation gap between
you and me with sneakers where I came
up with as Starsky and Hutch
Adidas dragons, Adidas country,
Nike Cortez,
which I picked up and I loved yesterday
and I was called at these man with the
red one, you know the white with
Forrest Gump and that's what kills me.
You go Forrest Gump. Well that's what
he ran in. I know, I didn't know that.
So he ruined those sneakers.
Yeah,
because he got a pair of them and that's
when he put them on and he just left
the house to started running
and then you see them get older.
But he kept those on the whole time.
Beard when you really love those
sneakers students. So, so clean.
And then what has somewhere around
would Shaq came into the league?
Like the sneakers just got so bizarre.
Like I remember one time he had,
it looked like a bullseye and the circles
just kept getting bigger and bigger
and bigger. The ones who, when he had,
when he was on in Orlando
and I was looking at those
things and I remember those
younger kids can all look at the shacks
and got the shacks and I was looking at
going at that. It looks lazy. Ugliest.
Now the shafts were fucking those Red
Adidas Yoga. I remember one time. Yeah,
but those Adidas I have are just classic.
They'll raise red or red with white
stripes and they're clean dude.
But I remember one time we
were on the road somewhere.
I haven't watched blog gray ones.
You've just bought gray ones. Yeah,
they're right there. They're all
fucked up. No. Yeah, dude, you are.
We were on the road and I was standing
to the right of the stage and I was just
going out there, watch some of your set
and everything like that, and I just,
for 45 minutes we're staring at your
Adidas and even list I was even listed.
I was just like, those
are clean. All right.
But those red ones are
one of my favorites.
You can see the ones hanging in there.
Yeah. On the on the bottom right.
That's Adidas country. The white with the
green. Those are those for me. Those are,
that's, yeah, that reminds me of
like 1976 Olympic Games. Yeah,
like like you know, led you
to, that was about 1978 yeah.
Due date is country flat and I can't,
that's, that's too, that's too old, dude.
I had to stand, but then you and then
the ones that, hey, six are cool.
Those are basics of cool, but then
the, then the other one's red.
Those are Adidas dragons. Smith's.
You've got black Stan Smiths.
You got Dick. I am the old clay got the
old school and they got Nike Cortez.
That's where I can't get,
that's where you lose me.
Like if I look at all your things,
you've got to,
you got to Stan Smith's
on top with your crazy.
You got to read the a six I could go with,
you got the Cortez I could go with and
then all of a sudden it gets down to the,
to the Bruce Jenner.
It's like you've said all the shadows.
I looked like a punter in 1974 yeah.
Those look like to punt.
Still a puzzle that doesn't
like old school soccer
shoes. I love wine. But yeah,
that's like you. You got
the leg. Would you have,
or like those Jordan's you have right
now that's like say should have the
blinking light in the back for a little
kid because it's got the infrared color.
That's what you don't like about,
yeah, somewhere around there.
They made the oh no's.
Yeah, that shit. And when,
when the sunglasses starting to having
the neon green or the neon pink,
the all along the side,
that's when the outfielders we're
in the Oakleys that the shiny,
they were big and shiny.
No,
just like every due to put Mousse in his
hair and had a chain around gold chain
around his United in the late eighties
had the fucking, those, those,
they would like the Tom cruise shaped
sunglasses from risky business and on the
side it was either lime. Oh aw,
that's terrible. Yeah. That's when I,
when those colors were in, I never
looked more pasty cause I just could not,
I could not pull them off.
So I had to just stick with my whole life.
I've dressed like Malcolm
young to be honest with you.
Did you ever wear Cavariccis ze couch?
I got with one of my first ever war I had,
I had z cavalry
with the Cosby sweater,
driving gloves for whatever reason,
rough on yesterday. Okay. And uh, and
a, a waist linked like leather zip up.
Ah. And I think I had a
hat on too was bad dude,
you and Z calves,
because I grew up in an Italian
neighborhood assumption and the kids,
they all warm. But like I remember they
were the four g Owen's, there was a,
and they just all had them.
I never wore them.
I never wore as coverage and
it just didn't, it wouldn't
have looked comfy pants.
He had no puffy up top and
then tapered taper down.
But it was the MC hammer pants.
It was basically the dressy and they
were pleated. Oh. Oh, that was so bad.
They were awful.
And they crushed,
it was like one detail that
would make any pair of pants bad.
They took like all five and they
just throw it in one, you know,
it's like that a were the mystery meat,
you know what I mean?
We just throw it in upon,
give it to the soldiers. Ah,
I remember one time I put
on pants and Stacy goals.
Those have pleats in it and I've,
yeah, no they're not. And she goes, no,
you can't do it unless you go into
an eighties party. You cannot,
you can't have that on any
fucking level. But, um, uh,
I wasn't gonna say, yeah,
so dude, you, you know,
you have no idea what you're in for
tomorrow. They'll go into the desert.
Got me excited. Like, Oh yeah, I
never seen like, you're going out,
you're going to butcher shops. You
can be, I made the big square ice.
He'll make you get nuts with the ice.
I was like, this is going to be nuts.
I it in a book. You know what really got
me? I saw a football and a pump. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, dude, we can be out on the
golf course. Ah, fucking lie had,
makes the sickest fucking breakfast
sandwiches DOJ going, you know,
what's the greatest thing is
when we pull up at this point,
we're becoming that tailgate that people
look over going, ah, they make an x,
why we should run eggs.
You guys are the guys at the Rose Bowl.
Like you'd becoming all that good.
But there's always the,
I don't think you get your official,
like you're,
you're the bad ass tailgates until
you're literally dragging a smoker in and
there's a bus. No, when you have like
the satellite dish and you got like a TV,
like those girls guys, we hung
within, uh, for the ut game. Yeah.
Now giants where the giants play as a guy.
He basically painted a school bus giants
and then he's got the tarp over and
like that, like the TV's on, like
those guys are staples there.
You guys aren't that yet. Are
you on? Okay. Okay. No. But
they, they, uh, those guys,
I went with some guys,
uh,
and Cleveland long time ago I went to a
browns game and there was some guys out
there that bought a short bus and they
painted it, this, this and this shit.
They painted it Cleveland Brown colors.
And then they had this dad,
this crank on the back
and on top of the bus.
Like these goalposts would come up and
you'd be in the parking lot and you'd
kick field goals. Oh my God. Anyway, damn
it. Oh, I think I saw that on TV. Oh,
is all they might've made it did up.
Fox did a thing on that
guy and they were like,
and people could line
up to kick field goals.
They were doing it at the Cleveland.
I don't know if it's the same one because
sometimes people see ideas and they
take, so, okay, but this was a
Cleveland Guy, isn't that awesome?
And then they really played like full
contact beer pong. They went nuts.
And I remember I tackled the guy
from John Lawrence from hilarity.
I tackled him and somebody had just
dumped the hot coals on the knee,
went right down on it and he got like
almost borderline second degree burn on
right under his kneecap and
he's putting snow on it.
I felt horrible and he was laughing.
He didn't care. Maybe I'll do that.
What's one of the sickest games ever?
As far as like the weather we showed up
and it was just that fucking Lake Erie
snow,
but it was just like,
it was just fucking cold
enough for it to be snow.
So it was wet snow and there was some
guys standing there, this fucking guy,
he had like a high school Letterman
jacket on. He was this skinny dirt bag,
look and fucking, you know the, the Dale
Earnhardt and mustache. Why are we guy,
no hat.
And he had like that fucking straw hair,
full head of hair but straw here do it.
And it was just,
he had like an inch of snow on his fucking
head and somebody finally just pulled
out an awful old Cleveland hat and put
it on his head and he just goes, yeah,
thanks. He just sort of shook his head,
do it and I swear to God it was like,
like the amount of snow that
came off of his fucking head.
Like if that guy didn't give him that hat,
I was looking at that,
looking at the guy going,
that guy,
if this guy stays out in the elements
for an entire football game where he's at
now, he, this guy is going
to die. It's fucking insane.
So this won't be, it'll be a little
cold tomorrow, but we bring like a,
we bring like three cords of woods,
so you know,
if it gets a little cold with the whiskey
and the system and I don't get cold
and I haven't got it doesn't get cold.
And with the Whiskey,
I'm going to be drunk kid, dude.
It is not, there's California.
How calls are going to beat them off?
Forties fifties it's gonna be a,
it's going to be like 39 degrees,
40 degrees.
If it stays not in the twenties
39 40 duties. That's like
47 40 Shelly. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
You're going to be getting
up and someone's at first
thing going to get as an
ice cold beer, which is not what you need
to warm up. I'm telling you man, pardon?
No,
but as soon as I'm going to be warm as
soon as the goes birthing heater heater,
if you want to hit it. Yeah, it's great.
It's one of my favorite things
is after a shell, after shell,
what would it was me,
you and Barton.
The best thing about touring with
bill is we all have a schedule.
We all have a system and we're
like the little brothers, right?
So then bill goes up and we always go our,
after our sets he bring bill up after
our sets we're going to go and do it.
So I go into the green room and Barton
extent it goes like he makes it,
he makes us thing with his face
where he gets real happy. He clearly,
he clenches his teeth and he makes a
fist and he smiles with his teeth clinch
and the fist shakes and he goes and then,
and then comics when pop
you want to pop. Like he just makes you
feel like anytime you have a drink it's
like he's, he's unbelief he could make,
he could make like doing feel okay
him.
Do you want to borrow for your lateral
and it's great the way presented it.
I'll take a pump but um, no dude.
You know what made me laugh?
I thought about this and I hope you
remember this because you made me think
about it cause you know I'd be talking
Shit right at a game with you going to do
dude. If they got that field go, think
back at the truck. I'm going to kick.
I guarantee you I kicked her in a role.
Like I would be talking shit.
Oh he would go beyond
that. I could, I could hit,
I could hit 48 yard at. You'd
be like, as you're doing it,
you don't keep just making up shit as
you call it. The funny thing, he says,
me and you were at Monday
night football in New Orleans,
remember against the
eagles. Oh God. We saw Vic,
we saw Vic and uh, and that was
when Andrew [inaudible] stadium.
And that was when Andy Reed was on
his way out. And I knew when they,
they just couldn't win, even know Vic
was doing okay man, you leave hammered.
And we're like, dude, we got along,
walked in him and we got a, we got along,
walk back.
So some guy standing next to us and
he hears us and he offered us a ride.
He was a complete stranger. You don't
remember this. And he goes, Oh yeah,
that's right. And he goes, he goes, dude,
I'll give you, he goes, you guys want,
if you guys want a ride,
I mean you just looked at each other.
Didn't know this guy from
Sam, didn't know. And we were
just like, yeah, all right.
And all of a sudden we got into a yelling
match cause I said I could throw a
college football 50 or so and I said I
could throw a pro football 45 you go,
you know you're not throwing
a provisional. How fuck.
And we start getting,
and the guy left like right.
And so it was the way he was just
left. That's right. He walked away,
said yes to a stranger and he listened
to this nonsense and just walked away.
He was like, I want no part of these two
and I guarantee you it was more me. No,
I'd probably get real angry over nothing.
I get angry over nothing and do two.
I sort of got one major shit happens.
I don't flip out.
Not all your fucking huge app.
Ah, fuck you gonna do all right.
How do we get out of this? But little
shit makes me calm and cool with anything.
Like he could be like, dude, did you
hear about songs? We'll do. He's gonna,
he's gonna fuck it and it'll be an awful
tragedy and you'll be like, can't do it.
That's bad. But you know, he could do this
and heal better it, you're like, well,
Bill's real positive. And then
somebody, it'd be like, dude,
just last star wars movie and
you just like, come on. Why
fucking hilarious dude. Eh, it isn't.
It's one of my weaknesses all that.
When we got water damage in the house,
I flipped out about that. But uh,
by the way, dude, challenge was
awesome. Generally speaking,
I'll clean, clean house,
clean up the wife because of
the wife. So, um, so anyways,
we get on to sit here and we got to
wrap this thing up here cause uh,
I got the fuck and I gotta make some pies.
Fee Jackass is tomorrow.
That's the fact that you do that
dude is little individual pies.
You can be thrown down
with the fucking ice cream.
You're going to be so fucking
hammered at that point.
Then he get a smoke with fucking
cigar. Yeah. Then you got it.
Then you've got to go watch the game.
That's the funny thing about it.
It's the funniest thing is
everybody's like, Ahhh, but
Bart, nick, he goes, hey dude,
I gotta be honest man. The
worst part of that. The,
the day has gone into the game
and I'm like, people do lie ahead.
Ly heads saved bargainings ass last year
they were going to throw him out cause
he just sat down somehow. I don't
know how, what did he do? Well,
I don't know how you get separate, how
you get separated from Joe Barden. Nikki,
such a big guy. We somehow lost
him. Like he was a toddler.
He's as big as the Lyman.
Right.
And he just went over and he just sat
down and he was drunk and he couldn't
produce his ticket or while I don't
know what was going to just sort of,
and they were all nervous.
Thanks you too.
It was like six of them
standing around going like,
how are we going to get this mallet?
And he was hammered in public.
He was sitting down. He, we,
like a lot of people are hammered
in public when they're there,
but they're walking to the bathroom,
but they're walking, you see?
But the second you sit down and you
look like you're gonna pass out and it
looked like a homeless guy. Oh,
he was in really rough shape.
They thought he was okay. They don't
understand Joe. Yeah. What are you going,
I'm arrested. I'm arrested. Arrested.
I've seen a display of Joe Barr.
Nicole, I'll know it'll never be
down. Well, he'd fuck it. We all that.
So they were about ready to kick them
out and that's when law had gave the
famous now famous the teddy bear speech.
Uh, he's a teddy bear. He's like, Hey,
you're the guy. You guys
want to take it. Right.
It just kept calling him a teddy
bear and they fucking bought it.
And he was able to bring
them back into the,
like to the seated area and sat him down.
And uh,
and I actually,
I remember telling people that story
last year and then other people used it
later on in the week and with
text me going, yeah, my buddy,
they were going to throw them out. I
just can't wait. He's a teddy bear teddy,
but adds great teddy bear diffuses
the situation. Dad's gray.
Oh No, Jace, Jace saved. But the
thing that people don't know,
and if those security people knew,
Bart,
nick Barnack was like member inch scar
face when he was just getting shot and he
was just gone and his arm was going
back, but he just kept shooting. Dude,
I saw we were in, we were in
Portland and a guy goes, dude,
this is the strongest suite in the
country. Like snoop dog gets his weed.
This is the weed, right? And
we're like, hi dude. I took one.
I took one hit of this thing and you
know I'm not a big weed smoke bill.
I was borderline not
okay for like 50 minutes.
Like I took one hit and I
was like, I can't touch that
again. Law had took three.
He just had this look,
pray for me.
He should have been praying
for two Barton smoke,
half of it with the other people.
He just get kept going around
and he smoked and drank.
I think he's just walking,
just walking sway, dude. And
he held it together. Dude,
animal animal. He doesn't go down too.
He won't go down. Never went down.
He won't go to Joel Amata. Ah, that's
great. Well I got to speak in a,
I'd check lamata Rappaport did a
whole a podcast on a raging bull.
Oh, did he do, and he showed me the names
of, I don't know if it came out yet,
so I'm not going to know.
Spoiler alert here.
He showed me the names of the people that
are going to be on just talking about
why they love that movie. Um, if
it's not out yet, look forward.
If it is out, listen to, it's
what I'm going to do to do,
you know what I listened to on,
I was driving out to go visit
some family out here and uh,
Nia put on this podcast of,
um,
they interviewed that
guy that just walked off,
walked off the base there or the
little area in, in um, Afghanistan,
the American troop that just,
just walked off and then got captured
by the Taliban and was there for five
years. They interviewed the Guy, dude,
it was, I listened to like three of them.
Why even know about that? Yeah.
Cause it's a big thing now.
Should they court martial Omer said
they just let them go cause he did it on
purpose. He said that because the
leadership was so fucked up over there,
he was trying to create a situation where
people above would listen because his
plan was to walk out and then come back
and I don't know what was going up but
like as American guy?
Yeah,
he just left the US base and
started walking towards them. Yeah.
And they captured him yet?
Well he didn't,
he didn't think he was going to
get caught. I I I'm such an idiot.
I'm already forgetting so much of it but
all I just remember was at the end of
it they're like this guy had
like some sort of fucking,
he didn't like where he was in life
and he had like a hero complex. Okay.
And he was trying to,
like,
he was trying to have like a Hollywood
movie moment and he got his dumb ass
caught and then all these troops had
to fucking go look for him and put
themselves in danger is
they were trying to get the,
the American guy to Pakistan because
they get them into Pakistan because we're
not at war with them. We can't just roam
all over the place and look for him. And,
uh, these fucking guys for like three
weeks straight, which is like to do,
could not rest. They have fun and have
dealt exactly and the fucking close.
We're almost fallen off just from
March and just trying to find this guy.
So some of them were saying
like, dude, I swear to God,
if I found the guy would've shot him.
And then the NPR lady's like, well,
I don't understand that. It's like,
how do you not understand that?
Oh fuck that guy. I wouldn't
even left the base. I'd be like,
fuck out of and scream animal. He left.
Yeah. I'm not calming. Yeah, it. Fuck you.
Yeah. You better find him
before I do. Yeah, Dude.
Fuck that guy because he
doesn't like where he's in life.
He puts some fucking risk of every one
of the guys said when I finally made the
trade off because we had to trade like
guys who Guantanamo Bay to get the
fucking guy back. And uh, they was
saying when the Apaches landed,
this one guy was saying he wanted to be
on the helicopter and they will like,
why? He goes, because I wanted to stay.
We're going to beat his ass. Fuck it.
I don't understand. Like I don't think
they literally would have shot him,
but somebody saying that like,
you had a fuck cause I'm going to fucking
shoot who somebody would have punched
him in the face and knocked
him out and be like, dude,
you're putting your fucking
absolutely soldiers resolute.
Fucking perhaps a fucking loser.
What, what was his end game?
What did he want to happen?
He wants, it was like,
it wasn't just his guys by the,
it was like an entire fucking platoon
of people just walking around.
That's her day and af fucking Dan is
Stan for a month trying to find this
fucking guy.
And they're all sitting there going like,
like one of the guys who saves
trying to keep the morale up,
make a jokes and shit,
and he goes into the,
in the end he goes to the back of your
head, you know, it's all bullshit.
And the employee are ladies like,
why
should I always make fun of the impure
people even though I love the station? Um,
that's ridiculous. He goes,
cause I knew it, you know,
after a certain amount of days of
guys in Pakistan, we just have to,
we got to at least look for the,
we have to do this level of force
to the Taliban. Fuck him up.
Well,
what,
because you know what was funny was
because of the amount of people that were
looking for him, they thought he
was a really important guy. Uh,
so I think that they went more
towards trading the guy. I mean,
I only listened to like two and
a half of them, but it's real.
I couldn't listen to the whole fucking
thing because once it was like,
once I found out the reason why he did it,
um,
I was just like, dude, you,
you get, you're, you're off.
You're just fucking fuck.
Yeah. And he's trying to
come off, like he says,
Guy who was really trying to do
something noble. It's like, no dude,
you have like some sort of hero
fantasy. It's a selfish move dude. Yeah.
And you were going to get in front of
like the brigadier fucking general or
whatever and they were going to
listen to you and be like, wow,
this guy's making sense. You
know, we're going to change
all of this. Yeah. I don't,
I don't, I, I, I was listening
to it and I just like,
the sickest thing was when he was
talking about like, he could do it,
he gets like 20 minutes away from the
base and realizes he makes this huge
fucking mistake and yeah.
And he wants to fucking go back.
But he got lost and then because
he's so fucking terrified,
his fucking ego kicks in again and he
decides to go even further into the shit.
Oh Man, do something. Like I was
just sitting there going like,
yeah, I do like your middle. Literally
keep palms are sweating but sort of,
but you know he's getting caught
and you know that he made it.
So that took a little of the edge
off. But it's just like, dude,
like they literally skin people alive
out there that fuck you're doin.
Do their cut and fix the
fucking heads off dude.
Well that's what they
would when they would do,
what's funny is the Afghany people are
on the podcast talking of some of the
guys that found them, not the Taliban
guys, but they're funny going like,
uh, they're like, what did he seem
like they will laugh and I go, yeah,
he seemed pretty scared. That was the
funny thing. Listen to the Afghan,
they just sound regular.
You know what I mean?
Cause there was makeup everybody out to
be a fucking monster and it was ray. Yay.
Seems scared.
So at one point they wanted,
because they couldn't speak English and
speak that they were trying to make them
feel like, don't worry, we're not
going to kill you at this, you know,
so there was some sort of dance that
they did and the, and he goes, freak me.
Exactly again,
we're going to kill this guy.
So they though they said that that calm
him down and the Afghany guy laughed.
He goes, Nah man, it made
them more nervous. Go Dude.
I would have done some sacrificial
like that's like the ready to kill,
Ya know? It was fucking funny. But with
the thing about it is, so what I liked,
the thing that I enjoyed
most about the podcast,
I was listening to somebody on the other,
or just a towns person over there just
sounded regular and cool because the way
they make it, see this is the
stories you hear over there.
When I picture Afghanistan,
I just picture a barren wasteland
and if you walk anywhere there,
somebody is going to jump out from behind
a rock and saw your head off as you're
alive. Yeah. I think
of, I think of it, uh,
while lighting the other part of the bond
fair foot turban going, we will, yeah,
they touch you think. Yeah. And then
he listen to this guy going. Yeah,
we did the common values. Like,
Nah, Beta one, nervous listening.
I'd fucking hang out with this
guy. So anyways, all right.
That's the Thursday afternoon
podcasts. Do it. I'm psyched.
You're out here on another great year.
A bunch of great shows.
So we're going to do tonight, uh,
downtown La fucking Rogan's at the uh, uh,
the Wiltern. Yeah. Lot of comedy
here tonight. I can't believe, uh,
enough people showed up for ours to
make it good shows here. Um, you know,
with rogue and a robe
with a fucking monster.
You ever seen him live long time ago?
Ah, unbelievable. So it's huge. Huge,
uh, like, uh, influenced when I,
when I first saw him as
far as like, like, uh,
there was such like a glass ceiling
to headlining and Boston. Yeah.
It was just like,
he just didn't have,
they had the legends and they weren't
leaving and they were fucking hilarious.
So there was only, so you had
a, he was the guy that like,
like I learned like you got to leave to
come back and headline because if you
stay here it's literally you
got to wait for people to die.
It's like getting fucking
season tickets to the packers.
It's like it's not happening man.
I got to go move to where in
Jacksonville I'll get 50 yard line seats.
That's kind of actually cool that Boston
like doesn't let those guys die out.
A lot of places.
Let those guys die out and they turn
into dinosaurs and it's almost like a sad
thing where the thing is
they didn't stop writing.
So they just kept going and
going and going and going.
So you got the both things like Rogan
I learned he had to leave and then come
back. And then with those
legendary guys in Boston,
I learned that you got to keep writing
if they cause some kept riding,
some didn't. And the ones
that didn't, the ax suffers.
But the ones who kept
writing, um, it's that, yeah,
you stay like contemporary.
Yeah. Um, so anyways,
I'm going to babble here so I get, I got
pies to make. I have paused some egg.
All right. Happy new year to everybody.
Thank you Jennifer for having me, man.
Happy New Year.
Absolutely. Thanks for, uh,
coming out on the road with me again
this year and thank you to everybody
listening. Everybody came up to the
shows. Everybody's been watching.
F is for family, uh, and telling
people about it. Um, it's doing great.
Great show. It's still in graduations on
that by the way. It's fucking awesome. Oh,
thank you. Thank you.
So, uh, please, you know,
keep telling people about the show
and I will talk to you guys on Monday.
Happy New Year.
Go Fuck you shoe
first. He's got me addicted to Florentines
podcast and now verse, he does like,
he does a pretty good Florentine
Florentine is the funniest motherfucker
Florentine complaining about anything.
Oh my God, that role buys camera robot.
You're fucking kidding me.
Garbage fucking Geo.
Like a Fox News robot. Fucking you got
that height robot the way it goes up.
All right. Like drags the word
out at half time. So again,
that's really good man.
He's fucking funny man. Let's get
it to that guy complained. Really,
really like we never seen a beautiful
woman before bud light commercials.
I can ridiculous. Um,
alright. Uh, we got here,
this is a okay.
Sunglasses.
There's some really some weird ones
this week. People like this guy says,
hey bill, I need, I need to uh, make my
listeners sent in like questions and shit.
And I read it just to let you know.
Billion.
I need to ask you a
very important question.
My wife makes fun of my
choice of sunglasses.
She's thinks they're not hip enough.
Um,
I told her I was wearing brown tinted
sunburst aviators since college,
before the whole aviator hype is there.
Aviator,
I don't even remember top. Yes, we say
it back then. Those people who in 1980,
right? Yeah. Who wanted to be like
Tom Cruise. You know, my neighbor,
when I was growing up, any movie that
Tom Cruise was in, he got into that,
like whatever. It was like a top
gun. He joined like the fucking, uh,
no, he, no, he joined like the, the,
the, the, the air force reserves,
the alligator on it. He joined
that and then, um, days of thunder,
he started racing cars. No cocktail.
He became like a bartender.
His Rich Dad got him out of
the fucking reserves. Yeah.
He started getting into that.
And what else did he do?
There was like three things.
So it kind of became this running joke,
like whatever,
fuck a Tom cruise movie was coming out.
And then eventually he moved
out to la finally. Just, well,
why don't we just be a fucking actor,
you know,
so not to actually join
the fucking air force.
That's a don't know what ever happened
to him. So anyway, aviator glasses,
which were, yeah, the Tom
Cruise fan slash date rapist.
Remember that fucking kid
I was talking about him.
Do you remember that kid who he had the
rough sex with a girl on them in central
park and she died? No, you're too
young for that. Yeah. This guy. Yeah.
Fucking psycho. No, he killed
her. He tried to, he tried to,
he tried to say that they,
that she wanted rough sex,
it was consensual and I don't know
what it is. He accidentally killed her,
whatever. I mean the whole of the
meetings who are killing it. Yes. Price
kill it.
Crushed it.
Fucking crushed it. Um, so
anyways, do, that's fucking
brutal. So anyway, put this guy,
you know what actually made me mad when
he got out of prison? Not only that, that,
that he got out of on two loves
and maybe mad, first of all,
the guy got out of prison,
but uh,
the idiots on the news going off on the
guy was saying, because when he got out,
he wasn't on parole because he did all
his time because he didn't get time off
for good behavior because they were just
like, you know, he had fights in prison,
he was selling drugs and blah, blah,
blah. It's like, yeah, the, all the,
all that that says in there
is he didn't get raped.
He did what he had to
do in there to survive.
So on some level yet you have
to respect that because that's,
that's the big fear is a guy. Did he
raped a girl or it was just rough sex?
I don't know what he did. I don't know.
What has such a big difference though?
Well, I don't know if he
went like Ron our tests,
like it was going good and he was
excited and then he fucking elbow.
Why are we joking about this?
Fucking started pounding his chest and
then they didn't show the replay because
it was a home game.
Um,
no, he, he fucking a, I dunno how long did
it, do they let them out of jail? Yeah,
he did like all 15 or 16 years because
they couldn't get him on murder because
he said it was like, I know like
on, on rape trials like that, what
they always do,
like the,
the hardest thing to get them on
is when they say it was consensual,
so then all DNA is out the fucking
window. Then you have to like, it's,
it's, it's, it's the
worst fucking thing. If,
if somebody does that to a woman that
they should be. Honestly they should.
They should just,
they should have like a flame thrower
and they should just have it pointed at
the defendant and Jerry,
would you like to read on
the count of a rape leave?
Find him guilty in the first degree it
says just light them on fire right in
front of the family. Yeah, right in front
of it. Right in front of the family.
That's how I would run it. Just same,
same thing with a child molester star.
That's the word I'm lessons.
That's it. Sean molested.
I would actually have them get chased
by rabid dogs first and then to descend.
He got fucking,
the Sandusky guy should get fucking
drawn and quartered in the courtroom.
I always put his fucking
body parts in her.
He should be underneath an oil tanker
and then they should drive it to fucking
or is that all you've got to drive
a boat, drive it to like, fuck man,
that's walking this earth these.
If that's what I would do with that guy,
what I would do with that guy.
Well,
I would go into shark infested waters and
I would give him a bunch of paper cuts
and at time to the front of,
Oh my God, I never heard of
that one. That's, that's a
good one, man. Well, Paul,
you've got understand, wait, when you
do something like that to somebody,
you didn't just,
you,
you ended that kid's life and then you
affect the generations of people because
who they're going to marry, how they're
going to treat the person they married,
how they're going to treat their kids,
and then the treatment of the kids,
how they're going to act in society,
society. It just, it creates,
it's like that little Confucius thing
when you drop the pebble in the still pond
and the ripples just go like that. He got
a little poetic on you. It's like that.
No, see, that's what I say. Time
to the front of a boat. Paper cuts,
shark infested waters.
And that's it.
And you know what's fun and this
is the thing about it. That's fine.
That'd be awesome. Um, and
it's still wants stop him.
It's the one stop it from happening, but
you should just start weeding them out.
Like that's a sickness man from young.
That's fucking crazy, man. Yeah.
That's just uh, uh, and it ruins the lives
of everybody but put the kid forever.
Yeah. So why you saying
what I just said Paul. Oh,
did you set it up so you won't even
listen to the typical comedian you're
thinking about what you were going to say?
Literally exactly what I just said. No,
I was thinking about the singing.
I was thinking about him actually like
hitting the thing like a boat. Oh,
that's right. You got, you got that. You
got that weird fucking shit where you,
you every once in a while you think
about doing crazy stuff, right?
I was getting nervous about
admitting this type of stuff.
Like someday if you're like
on trial, like, you know,
I'm going to get put in contempt of court
because that's still never rat you out.
But it'd be like,
we were talking about,
you guys talked about this on the
podcast, but it killed me. It was a joke.
Oh, we didn't ask the fucking guys
question here. We were talking about avs.
He said,
what's the breakdown of Douchey sunglasses
verse acceptable versus acceptable
ones?
What kind of sunglasses do you wear?
And does Nia have any say in the matter?
I imagine you were very nonthreatening,
low profile shades.
I can't tell if that's an insult or if
he's calm. Sounds like an insult, right?
Um, no, I don't think it's an insult.
I think this guys genuinely wants to
know what you could wear to make his girl
stop trashing them. Well, this is
what you have to do. First of all,
depending on where you are
and your relationship is,
is if you feel secure
in your relationship,
maybe she's just doing you a solid and
telling you that you look like a Douche.
But if she's always telling
you everything what to do,
that you have to continue wearing those
glasses and you have to wear them over
to her mother's house. Defiance, yes. And,
and wear them into the house and don't
take them off when a mom's talking to you.
That's like a buddy, a buddy of mine.
Right. Do Women know? Women just,
I just want me to say something
real quick. Oh God. More
women trashing her slip.
You're going to be nice to them.
Like,
could you like a guy's really thinking
about it and this happens all the time.
This guy's got a genuine concern here.
But like for like,
I've heard of guys going,
yeah,
my girl just looked over at me and
looked at that shirt and goes, oh,
it's such a turn off. Take
it off and I want to be, it's
in my mind, I'm just like,
I want to be like, dude, shut up.
Are you at? Yeah. But those guys,
those guys deserve it. They
fucking deserve it. Paul, if you,
if you let the woman in your
life talk to you like that,
they fucking deserve it the same
way a woman deserves it. If,
if that guy is a fucking as a minus,
then beating the shit out of you.
But I got it. Yeah. Mine isn't
beating the shit out of you,
but like if they beat you up and
that's just complete bullshit, quit.
If they're walking around being a
fucking asshole, disrespecting you,
that that's on you. Okay.
You guys break up with them.
But what if the guy says to him, you shut
up and I'm wearing the shirt. Shut up.
Yeah. Is he a dick now? Right. But
then it's like, oh, I'm like, I don't,
that's a total turnoff that discussed.
We take that off. Just flip it around.
What if you ever said that to
you girl? Exactly. Disgusting.
It makes you look fat.
You come on, you'd never do that.
Even if you said that disgusts me,
that would be it.
Listen,
here's my aunt threw the fucking
dessert that night at the meal. Well,
here's my answer to your, to your,
uh, your listener's question here.
If you like 'em dude, and you look in the
mirror and you go, you know something,
I liked it. I liked the glare. I
like, if it's orange tint or whatever,
you'd like it fucking where Paul,
you know some,
that's why you and your was so comfortable
to hang around because how many times
you guys tell each other go, fuck you.
See you say go fuck yourself. Right.
You do that right now we'll just be like,
ah, you know, something shut like, yeah,
shut up. Not Enough. But Lloyd in a loving
way, like, uh, yeah, but you have to,
you have to keep them.
You got to keep off the same way.
She has to keep you off or you know,
she didn't keep you in check.
You'd golf fucking nine times a week,
right? Yeah, no, no, absolutely.
There's a fine line. And what's
like, you know, yes, exactly. Dude.
I had a buddy of mine,
he fucking,
we went fishing right when we
were done fishing. Uh, you know,
we drank a bunch of booze or whatever.
We were smoking cigars and his
wife pulls up and you know,
they told their kid about the
dangers of smoking, right?
So the kid starts fucking crying and blah.
There's all this big fucking thing.
And the kid,
the guy was literally in the dog house
and I guess maybe because the kid was
crying, I kind of saw her point, but
he's one of those fucking guys. I,
I wanted to save him. Like, dude,
you know what really helped
your relationship next time
you drop your kid off in
the car, take out a big fat fucking
Cuban and just light it up. Yeah.
And again,
what are you doing?
I'm smoking a cigar because I enjoy it
when I come home I'm going to watch a
game and I'm smoking this fucking cigar.
And when she says why you say,
because you can go fuck yourself and
that and I'm telling you it's a little
blunt. You can, you can
round off the edges.
I want to say you could go fuck yourself.
I'm just saying that would help you
a relationship. It's like that movie.
Remember that movie there with the
Kevin Spacey when she comes home?
What does that in the driveway? He's
like, that is a 1969 Firebird and he just,
I went out, bought it cause I
wanted it go fuck you. Like,
and you saw the look on her face.
There was a shift for the
better in that relationship.
But doesn't he die in the
end? I he get killed. I don't
know. It was that was that,
that was a weird one. He wanted to
fuck that 12 year old. Fuck that movie.
Sitting with rose petals falling all over
him. Um, so we're saying, you know what,
you, whether you were the God damn
sunglasses you want to surface, right.
Rather was
done with it.
Rather
rather
the and a dog base man,
wake
up,
shower.
No.
[inaudible].